these hats finally came in these are  customized hats if you want to zoom in a  little bit with the camera I don't know  if they can do it from back though or  not okay so it's it's a it's a uh these  will go out in no time they've already I  think there's only like 120 of these  left but it's the valuetainment shield  on the front on the side it says future  looks bright right here and then on the  lid It also says the future looks bright  with the inside you're gonna get one  having valuetainment all over it so if  you haven't ordered one of these we got  them in Black we got them in red we got  them in Black uh uh white and they will  go very very quickly so if you want to  put the link below if you're a  valutainer if you followed a podcast if  you represent free enterprise free  market freedom of speech you're a free  thinker and you want to represent that  in the market go get yourself a value  payment